vous entendez c'est le bruit des
batailles et des vies perdre
[Applaudissements]
jadis cela nous penny d'être la cause de
tant de désespoir
mais maintenant
leur tri motors
en france
la beauté est mon arme
ouah miroir mon beau miroir qui est la
plus belle
entre toutes
tu es la plus belle mais il en est une
autre qui est appelée à tous surpassés
dévore son coeur et tu vivras
éternellement trouvé deux mois pour la
traque est quelqu'un que n'effraie pas
les ténèbres de la forêt
pourquoi at elle compris à vos yeux cela
ne te regarde pas et si je refuse
[Musique]
des lèvres rouge comme le sang le noir
comme la nuit
apporte-moi ton coeur ma chair sous la
manche